the last time
i spoke
we were talking about the disjointness
problem
we
discussed in some detail
the proof of
the information theoretic proof of
this result and
so
yeah my
plan for today
is
to see some applications of
communication complexity
in
analyzing other
problems in computational complexity
we
probably have time just to see two such
examples but we will see them in some
detail
good
yes so this one-fourth will sort of
appear in the omega here so based on
that so
so
depending on
the time we have
we'll talk about
the application of
communication complexity to formula
complexity
and
to
showing lower bounds in streaming okay
so both these are lower bound results
so you have a boolean function f
on n variables
and you want to build
a boolean formula for this
so
so boolean formula is a tree like this
but the only gates i allow
are ands and ors
and the negations
appear
only at the leaves
and such a formula computes a boolean
function
we would like to understand
how
efficient
we can make this formula for computing a
given function f
there are two measures
one is
size
and by size let us say
we just count the total number of
literals that appear in the leaves or
the depth
the length
of the longest path
from the root
to a leaf
so
for formulas
the depth and size
are pretty closely related
so
we'll focus mainly on depth today okay
so
size is exponential
in depth
so this
is a
problem of analyzing the complexity of a
boolean function f
now it turns out
that this is connected
to communication complexity
and this connection was
through what is called the karczware
victorison
i'll just call it catchment victim
so here at the moment there is only one
input
and on that input we are trying to
compute the function
and
in the kashmir regression communication
problem there are two parties
alice and bob
i'll just tell you what their inputs are
going to be and what they're supposed to
do with them
now alice is given an input x
on which
the function computes
is on which the function is one
okay and bob
is given
an input on which the function is zero
and what's their task
they need to find an index
where
x and y differ x and y must differ
because
the output of f is different
on them
and
alice and bob given x and y need to
communicate
and determine
so there is
now there may be multiple eyes so
strictly speaking this is not
a function that they are trying to
compute of their inputs
for the same x and y there are
multiple acceptable answers i
if the x and y differ in many places you
are free to provide any i okay
so
this is
what kashmir invictus
and actually
it was observed
perhaps even
before
so this is
they
observe
that
the communication complexity of this
problem
is exactly the same
as the formula complexity of f
so once again let me write it down and
then
so the communication complexity of the
karcher regression problem for f
i mean the deterministic
communication complexity
and why is this true
so when i say depth of a function
i mean
minimize over all formulas
computing that function of the minimum
of the depth so
so the minimum depth to compute f is the
same as the minimum
communication
over the worst case input for this
problem
all right so
this is an equality but actually we will
use this equality to show
a lower bound on depth of f
that is
we will show a lower bound
on
the communication complexity of the
karchmann victorian game associated with
a certain function and from that we'll
conclude
that the formula depth for that function
has to be large so that is we will only
be using this direction
in other words
we want to show that if depth of f
is small
then there is
a short protocol for this problem and
let us just verify that it's a more more
or less straightforward thing
so imagine we have a formula for f and
it has a certain depth
and i want to
let's say the depth is d
and i want to
show a protocol
for that communication problem
which works with just d bits of
communication
so how does that work
keep the input x
here and feed the input y
the output gate
evaluates to different values in on x it
evaluates to one on y it evaluates to
zero okay
so when alice observes this she sees
a one and a one feeding into this and
gate whereas for bob at least one of the
two gates
is feeding a zero
on bob's input okay so
all the and gates
are where
it is alice's turn to communicate
and the or gates
are where it is bob's turn to
communicate okay so this you can just
turn this tree into the protocol tree
replace
this
sorry and is where bob
and r is where it's alice i'm sorry yeah
so now bob
sees a particular zero one of these two
is zero so
bob points alice
in that direction
okay
now it's an or here
and
alice had once feeding into this ore
whereas bob has a
zero
feeding into this so for bob both these
must evaluate to zero for alice
at least one of them evaluates to one so
alice says oh go this way
there is some
difference in our input in this part
okay
and depending on
whether it's an or gate or an and gate
one of them can make progress
down this tree
and after these steps they would have
hit a leaf
and this leaf must be evaluating
to a different value for alice and bob
and they have found the i where x i and
y i differ is this
totally obvious
and this goes the other way also that is
if you have a protocol
then you can somehow take the protocol
tree and just
like magically relabel
and
alice and bob by ands and ors and
it somehow computes the function okay
but that is not important for us today
they also observed this but they didn't
use it in
uh as spectacular away as karcher and
victorson did okay and
i think it was probably forgotten but
so this the the point is that this uh
game goes by the name cards for rigged
game but it was observed before also
so
i want to so this is a general framework
but today i want to use this
to show a lower bound for a particular
function f
okay
so the function f
that i want to
special sort of function and
just
tell you what this function is
so
this is a function on graphs
so there are
three n vertices
so imagine that this graph
an undirected graph on three n vertices
has been provided to you
by means of its adjacency matrix
okay and
we want to know if there is a matching
in this graph a matching means
a set of disjoint edges
whether this graph admits
n
disjoint edges
does this graph have a matching of size
n okay so this is a boolean function
on
3n
choose 2
variables
yep
3n choose 2 variables and the final
answer we want to know
is
0 1 yes it has a matching of size n
no
it doesn't have a
so
don't take these parameters n and 3n
seriously i mean
the general matching problem also can be
shown to be hard using the same method
but it will be easier for me to work
with these parameters yeah that's the
reason i stated it like this okay so the
question is this
we have this particular boolean function
on three and choose two variables
and
we want to show that
if you want to compute this boolean
function
using a formula then the depth
has to be large okay so the theorem
so
that means if you want to build a
formula
for this
uh you will need
linear depth
uh question are you doing monotone sorry
i'm doing monotone
yeah
it could have been more interesting
though
i know i know
i'm sorry i've messed it up okay so
yeah so i there was one more thing to
write here uh
my notes which i forgot and yeah sorry
got everybody interested
so
if f
yeah so just uh i'll come back to this
so if f is monotone
f is monotone yeah
then we can expect f to be computed by a
monotone function that is there are no
negations
at the leaves
any monotone function can be computed by
a monotone formula
so
we can talk about the monotone depth
of f
that is the size the depth of the
smallest monotone formula computing f
and
the following thing is true
and i'll just write an m and let me just
explain so what's the karcher reduction
game now
alice is given an input on which
the function f is one bob is given an
input on which
the function is zero
since it's a monotone function
these two inputs must have a position
where
alice has a one and bob has a zero
it's not good enough for them to find a
position where they differ they need to
find a position
such that x i is one
and
and y i is zero bob has a zero and alice
has a one in that position okay and the
same sort of translation continues to
work and this is what we'll be using
now let's start again yeah question
just define what a monitor or blue link
function is
monotone boolean function is that is if
you flip any bit from zero to one the
value of the function can't go from one
to zero
so
if you
imagine the set of all inputs
as a
this is the all zeros and this is the
all ones
then
the monotone function takes values
one after sometime and is zero so it's
just that
cube has been kept like this
so it's monotone
thank you please keep asking
okay
so
we'll show the monotone depth
of matching
is
omega n
and how will we show this
we actually show
that
to show that this depth is large we can
use this theorem and show that the
communication complexity of the
associated
carcinogen problem
is large
and to show that this communication
complexity is large
one second
show that this communication complexity
is large it's enough to show
that
this disjointness problem has a large
randomized communication complexity but
this was already done
so what we are doing is just an old
fashioned reduction
we will show that if you could solve
this karcher vectors and communication
problem efficiently then actually
you could have solved the disjointness
problem efficiently
this is a deterministic protocol
using this deterministic protocol
we will construct a randomized protocol
for the disjointness function and this
is where there is a slight novelty
this translation from formula depth to
communication complexity at the moment
is all deterministic
but
it's a very beautiful observation that
we can use
the deterministic
protocol for
this problem to
add a little bit of randomness
to arrive at a randomized protocol
for the disjointness function
question i'm not familiar with this uh
depth concept but is there a connection
between depth and the computational
complexity of the
problem yeah so
so it depends on the model of
computation yes so right now if i
declare my model of computation to be
formulas
then
you mean the running time
run okay so running time
is related to
circuits
okay so you might say that the size of
the smallest circuit computing
f
is related to the running time okay now
the difference between a circuit and a
formula
is
that we don't
we allow only fan in
fan out one
in a formula
okay
let's see see but can you run this and
find d right looks like you can run this
in roughly time d times n maybe or
something like this
for the protocol but the
to compute the function of course you
have to
do a two to the d size computation
inputs can be replicated
sorry yeah yeah oh none of my yeah
oh okay right
i guess you're not trying to say nc
yeah i'm not yeah
so there is a model of computation so
this is looks like parallel computation
you can see this
depth corresponds to parallel
computation
all right okay so our purpose is just to
show that
any formula for this function any
monotone formula for this function must
have large depth
question
it looks like some of those um x i are
negated but i thought the function was
supposed to be monotone so okay so this
picture was drawn
uh
when i was discussing this
and i did not erase the negations when i
came down here but right now we are
talking about a formula like this with
no negations
i anywhere my question is if you were
trying to prove the problem's mp part
sorry okay can you use this kind of
bound to prove the problems and be hard
if you have a low bound on the depth
does that connect to uh
you could use it to separate
okay so
just like np
p there's these are
classes
yeah these are classes inside of p
called nc
and if you want to know if there are
there's a separation between
say n c and p then we would like to pick
a problem in
p and show that it does not have
efficient formulas of a certain depth
okay
and this is along those lines
but here we are making a restriction we
are assuming that the formula is
monotone yeah
all right so we'll just uh
do
show
this
but the matching problem corresponds to
a molecule function right
yeah matching problem corresponds to a
monotone function
but
even though the function is monotone it
is
not
necessary that the optimum circuit for
it
should be monitored
and it's not there's no lower bound on
the
actual depth
so is there a lower bound on the depth
note m depth
for general matching problem yeah just
curious
oh so m sorry sorry i i missed it
entirely
because the m is so small
now i realize that there's actually a
new definition here so m def is the
amount all the monotone circuits the
larger steps
smaller yes now i got it but then there
may be other implementation which could
have smaller depth but might use
negation even though the font
so what do we have
we have
alice and bob
this is the disjointness problem
and they need to determine
if s and t
are disjoint
so this was our disjointness problem and
what we are trying to show is that we
can solve the disjointness problem if
somebody gave us a protocol
for
the matching problem for the catchment
victorian game
for the matching problem okay
now
so given these sets we'll have to cook
up graphs
that we want to feed to alice and bob
so that the graph that we feed to alice
has a matching
the graph that
we feed to bob doesn't have a matching
and somehow from their answer we should
be able to deduce whether
s and t are disjoint or not
that's roughly what we are trying to do
so let me just quickly tell you how
these graphs are to be built so alice
builds her graph as follows
so there are these
3n vertices
so let me call this a 1 b 1 c 1
a 2
b 2 c 2
a 3 a n b n
c
so
i've at least got my number of vertices
right yeah three n vertices okay
now
the element one may or may not be in the
set
okay
if
it is in the set
alice puts an edge here
and if it is not in the set
she puts an edge here
this is a little bit of a hacky
reduction but just uh yeah
so if
the element is in the set
alice will
put the edge here otherwise she'll put
her edge here
now bob
what does bob do
so i'm going to do it in two steps so
right now bob also has the same vertex
set
a 1 b 1 c 1
a
n
b n
c n
so right now
here alice put some edges bob is not
putting his putting edges here he's just
marking some vertices okay and then i'll
build the real graph for bob here so
right now i'm just marking some vertices
and
which vertices to mark will depend on
his set t
okay so if
he puts circles
let's say around some vertices
so in each row he is going to put one
circle
and if
i
does not belong to t
then he puts the circle here and if i
belongs to t
he puts a circle in this column
so look at the ith element if it belongs
to t go to the ith row
and then put the circle in this column
and if i does not belong to t
put it here
before you do the reduction
so what what is the reduction supposed
to achieve so if they intersect what is
the what are these pair of instances
supposed to do and if they don't
i'll just
sorry am i jumping ahead what the
criteria yeah so
yeah so the way
i'm saying it you're jumping ahead but
just in a moment we'll both kind of
synchronize yeah okay
so let's just do this so we
take these sets
and build this graph okay so
i promise to give bob a graph i have not
yet given him a graph i have just given
him these vertices and some
set of vertices which she has marked
okay
let's call this set of vertices you
those that have been marked
what's the property
yeah
suppose
they both
alice and bob both have the element
there is an element i which is in s
and also in t
let's see what happens
alice will put an edge here
whereas bob will put his
circle far away from the edge
that means this vertex
will not cover
this edge
in the sense of vertex cover
whereas if either of them
misses the element i
then
the element that has been marked will
fall on the
edge so
here's the statement i want to make sure
so
i hope i got this right
so if
s and t are disjoint
then
suppose a particular element is not in
s is set the edge will appear
in the right column so no matter where
bob puts his
node they will intersect i mean the
vertex will cover the edge okay the only
case when you don't cover is when both
of them have ones
so it's
maybe what i wrote is not correct but
something like this is true okay
so we have sort of reduced not to the
matching problem but the so called
vertex cover problem that is bob's set u
covers alice's matching if and only if
the sets are disjoint
so now
yes the next step
i have to tell you alice's graph and
bob's graph
so alice's graph
is this
okay
so it consists of a matching
with n edges
there's one edge in each row
and edges okay now what is
bob's
graph
so bob picks some vertex
in his
let's call this v
we might as well pick the first one it
doesn't matter okay so picks some vertex
v
and
considers this set
u prime
which is u
deleting
so he
leaves this alone and just considers the
rest
okay and
the edge set of
bob's graph
is
u prime
cross product with
all the vertices
minus
i will draw a picture
alice has a matching
and bob
has
used to have this set
u
of vertices
so what does he do he just
drops one vertex
and all the rest he connects
completely
this is bob's graph this is alice's
graph let's call this g we call this h
once again
we had a disjointness instance we turned
it temporarily into a matching and a
vertex cover
this vertex cover i'm translating into a
graph with edges okay now the sorry
this graph
clearly has a matching of size n
and this graph
okay sorry this is u prime that is one
of the vertices was dropped and then we
built this now this u prime
does not have a matching of size n
because
what are the releases
how many are there right okay how many
are there so
in this
you used to have n vertices
one of the vertices i'm omitting
so u prime now has
n minus 1 vertices those n minus 1
vertices
are being connected to everybody else
so it's a pretty dense graph all the two
n all the three and uh yeah so there are
three m
three n
you're minus you're dropping one so it
should be three n
it should be two n s because what did i
do
there's two and outside n minus one for
u prime and the deleted vertex
which is the last one all right
so
there are three n vertices in all right
and there are these n minus one vertices
in u prime and they are connected to
everybody else
so that's right so
the one that we deleted i don't know
where it appears but yeah i've connected
them to themselves as well or sort of um
they're three n vertices total there's a
subset of n minus one correct and
it's just a complete bipartite graph two
complete bipartite how many vertices are
in this picture they're four n minus one
or three three yeah
so it's
it's complete bipartite with two n plus
one and n minus one adding up to three
you could also make that left portion a
complete thing it wouldn't matter
because it's a question of how many are
you matching from the right side there
are only n minus one vertices so
oh no no you can't do that you have to i
take that back sorry it has to be a
bipartite graph i'm leaving it as a
bipartite graph right now
once again let me start
how many vertices did i shade here n
okay i just removed the shading on this
so there are only n minus one vertices
that are shaded those i call
u prime
okay how many other vertices are there
in the graph two n plus one
okay
i collect every vertex in u prime to
each of these two n plus 1 vertices
that is my graph h
does this h
have a matching
no
because every edge is incident
on u prime and u prime has only n minus
1
so at least i mean i don't know what we
are going to do with this but
it looks like
the graph that has been provided to
alice
has a matching of size n
and the graph that has been provided to
bob
doesn't have a matching of size n
now we could
take this
to
um
this protocol that we have
for
the kashmir viktor singh
and it should come up with a certain
edge yeah now
this matching
has an edge
somewhere outside
because
there is an edge which is not incident
on this
now if
in the original graph here it was a
proper vertex cover that is these
vertices covered these edges
then there would be only one such edge
of alice which is in this region
the edge that was incident on the vertex
v
which we just removed from that edge
now v itself has moved here and that
edge also is here
but if
these vertices did not cover
these edges
yeah there would at least be one edge
which is
not incident on that vertex v
which is here okay so there is this
vertex v here
maybe there is an edge but there would
be at least one edge which is not
incident
on v and also sitting in this part okay
so when we feed
this particular graph
these graphs to the
to the
to this protocol it has to come back to
us with
one of these edges
okay now if it comes out
comes back with this edge
we would immediately know
that our vertex set
u
did not cover
yeah that is there was an edge that was
not covered by you and since
in which case
so that's what we wanted to know u so we
conclude that u does not cover alice's
matching so s and t must
intersect okay
however it is possible
that
even though there was this edge when we
fed this to the protocol it came up with
this edge
and now this edge is incident on the
vertex v that we deleted so we cannot
conclude that there was
an edge that was not covered by you and
because all the edges that we are being
shown
are
incident on our u okay so here is so so
far everything was deterministic but i
said
that so here's what they do
alice and bob they had these graphs they
apply a random permutation sigma so they
used shared randomness
and they just permute their vertices set
random
okay so this is cryptography so
why did so these two as far as we can
tell are symmetrically placed
why did this particular protocol choose
this
or choose this over this
well maybe it is hardwired that way the
inputs were such that it wanted to
choose this over this but now
we apply a random permutation
so there is equal chance of choosing
this edge and this edge just by symmetry
okay so this needs uh i mean nothing i
can say will convince you yeah okay so
but
you apply a random permutation sigma
and then feed it
to the carcinogen game
and if
and then ask if the answer so yeah so
you feed it to the uh
protocol and it comes up with an edge
it has to come up with an edge because
this graph doesn't have a matching this
graph has a project and we asked if
this edge
contains
sorry v
so we applied the permutation it came up
with an edge this
and it was this edge we translate we
kind of undo the permutation and check
whether it was the image
of one of the edges that intersected me
if it did then we say okay sorry we
cannot say that
whatever yeah that it
does not cover but if it so happens that
it comes up with an edge which is not
incident on v
then we know that that set u was not a
vertex cover
for this matching
yeah for
alice's graph and we'll be done
okay so i'll just uh stop your
question
right after like maybe you have creation
in such a way but they always like just
do is just to find an age which is the
incident on b
yeah but
the protocol does this particular
protocol when it gets a particular graph
it acts in a deterministic way and finds
a vertex okay
now
i'm going to apply a random permutation
now
you can imagine that there is a
permutation that
switches this with this okay
so that permuta the protocol itself is
still working on the graphs it's not
taking
the random permutation is advised and
then doing anything okay
so
yeah not saying it very well but because
there is randomness
it is as likely to pick this edge as
this edge
so you can find the vertex d right he
cannot find he doesn't know which is
vertex v but like if you if
if this protocol like say say see all
the vertices yes let's assume a very
simple protocol
vertices and then you find the vertex
which is
so they just share all their
data and then protocol just looks he
knows which vectors is v and he outputs
like that
but he doesn't know which vertex is v
but you know you will share all the data
well i don't
so
alice and bob while they are trying to
solve the disjointness problem
yeah they
pick this random permutation where did
my sigma go that was this permutation
sigma
this
alice and bob keep to themselves apply
this permutation and then feed that
permutation to the protocol yeah but
like let's say but correction
he just exchanged all over that all the
graph that's right
and then he looks then say alice knows
which is a vertex
v which is not
belong to
this itself u prime yes
and then you can just uh output where
the edge which is repeat
but but if there were two edges
if there were two edges
which were missing that
missing she is care about each of your
agents or anything only wants to chew up
she wants to mess up your argument
no i understand yeah yeah i think you're
helping her too yeah yeah it's so good
yeah please go ahead
there are two alices and two bobs right
okay so there is the alice
no no no sorry didn't mean to confuse
you this is the alice and bob of the
disjointness problem and these are the
ellis pride alice
of the
kashmir victorson problem
all right
alice and bob of the disjointness
problem apply the sigma build their
graph and feed only the graphs
so now just one moment when i apply
sigma
to this vertex b1
it has gone somewhere
okay
this alice and this bob are free to
share their inputs do whatever they want
they will not know which vertex
corresponded to b
one not only but they don't know that it
i mean it just looks equivalent to all
the other two n plus one vertices that's
sort of
yeah
okay great
that's why i said i'll not convince
anybody yeah okay yeah
yeah
so question sorry i didn't see you're
saying that basically like let's say for
example for example alice hat and bob
hat have the protocol where they just
share the graph and then they iterate
over the edges and find the first one
that doesn't uh
right and then if you
rearrange the edges in some arbitrary
order they'll find a different one first
but let's say they have a protocol where
alice hat and bob had say well here we
have the edges that or we have the
vertices and the edges that we were
given now we look at every edge
um you know uv and we see if it's
present in alice and not present in bob
and if that's true we also check whether
for example
uh virtus vertex u has at least degree
three or vertex u is part of a five
click or vertex u has or like this graph
is isomorphic to this very particular
graph or something right that's right so
that induces a bias yeah yeah so then
but you i understand that in a general
graph permutation doesn't
imply that every edge will appear
i mean with equal probability look at
the graphs i am building this is just a
bunch of matchings
this
is a bipartite graph complete bipartite
graph
yeah and there are these
some edges which are located as matching
isn't this completely symmetric
there is
those uh
special
you know features like five clicks and
uh you know
local trees or whatever are not present
this edge this edge and this edge
they're all
this is what like alone talk pattern the
pattern is the same yeah so if you
permuted and permute them
this needs some convincing yourself but
it's really beautiful
no
all right so
i have five minutes yeah so i'll
let's talk about the other application
and see what happens okay
sorry i didn't mean to stop the
discussion if you want me to say more
but i mean in the end so what you did is
the
result is that you get
probability that if you find the edge
which is incident to you
little v
yeah
okay so so if s intersect was empty
then you would
the probability that
this doesn't happen right
and if s
it was not empty
then this would happen with probability
something like one over n you know half
because maybe there are just two edges
it sometimes picks this edge sometimes
picks this edge
half now i said one fourth
and you just repeat this protocol a few
times don't worry about it i mean yeah
so
errors are but this is also on one side
it's a one-sided error if you find that
edge then you know that we did not that
special vertex v that you deleted
did not cover some edge and then you
let you just
think it over
versions of this argument where you have
a gap in the matching site
you want approximately
how delicate just
we can take it off like i'll take it
offline
i just want to
i mean in the time that i have i'll just
be able to tell you the problem and
a lower bound that can be proved for it
using communication complexity and
i'll tell you which problem the
reduction is
done from
okay so the problem is the following
so you have
a string here of k plus 1 elements
from some alphabet
so each of these a i's
is an element of capital sigma okay
and
yeah so
alone said we should remember that k is
the size of the alphabet is what's that
what is it anyway for us
so you have
a stream here which has k plus one
elements but they come from an alphabet
of size k
so some letter
repeats
and the goal is
to find out
which letter
has repeated
and we want to do this with small
amounts of space that is you have
a
computer
and this data is
going
in front of you and you have a small
amount of space
you can't keep the entire string with
you okay
but if
you have k plus 1 elements then you
would like to say that oh this element
repeated
now if you try to do this
deterministically
basically you can't do much yeah you
will need space
omega k
but there is a randomized protocol
with space
so actually so parikshith and i
we worked on this at some point and we
had a log cube algorithm but the
improved log squared k
algorithm is due to
algorithm right
we are allowed only one pass
so we don't i no so the point is that
log k squared is a lower bound
for this problem but right now
and the lock k1 is the one where exactly
one element appears twice and the
remaining appear
exactly one time
but here you're allowed
other inputs where
something can appear three times or four
times
so
turns out that whenever you have
situations where there is limited memory
yeah
you can turn that into
some sort of a communication protocol
that is if you have an efficient
streaming algorithm then that implies
an efficient
communication protocol for an associated
problem okay that is
you could perhaps cut the input into
this part in this part give this to
alice give this to bob and since we are
doing only one pass
tell alice you do all the work for the
first half of the time
give me the data and then i will
continue i being bob
for the rest of the time okay and how
much communication does alice have to do
well as much as the
space complexity of this problem because
she just conveys to me the
what's it called the state of the
algorithm and i continue from there okay
so if you could show that the associated
communication problem is hard
then you would have shown
that the streaming algorithm
requires large amounts of space
so the problem that
you can
probably try and
to understand why such an such a
protocol might exist i'm just giving you
uh communication problem here it is like
set disjointness
s subset of n
t
subset of n
but
the size of s
plus the size of t
is
say yeah
now when this happens
s and t definitely share an element
there's a guarantee
not
i mean there's a guarantee coming out of
just their sizes that they must share an
element and alice and bob need to find
that element
okay so find
i
sir
belonging to
this is the communication problem and
one round alice just needs to
send a message to bob
and bob should be able to figure out
what is the element that is common to
them
and
if you allow yourself randomness and
some small amounts of error
then actually you can do this
with
order
log squared k
make some communication i'll let you
think uh about how to do that okay
sorry what am i doing yeah yeah k has
turned into n yeah
i changed
n to k
to bring alone into it
you're working this talk
oh should you skip the k all together
yeah let's keep it as end now yeah i'll
otherwise keep making the same mistake
just two more minutes i'm over time and
i'll just tell you what it does
sorry i think mystic give my view
so how does the
space
and the
communication complexity is equivalent
can you yeah
it's not equivalent but a lower bound
for communication complexity implies a
lower bound for space
as follows suppose you had an efficient
streaming algorithm for this problem
okay so then i cook up
a corresponding sorry
why is kashmir victor's instill here
i hook up a different communication
problem as follows so
that is
so you take
you take these inputs
the first k over two inputs let's say
and give them
to alice
and the remaining inputs to bob
and
this particular streaming algorithm did
something okay
then alice and bob simulate the
streaming algorithm
and come up with the same answer
okay so we would have given a streaming
protocol streaming algorithm we would
have come up with a protocol for some
problem
okay
now we independently show and that that
problem
is hard anyway
hard
in terms of communication okay and from
that
i claim that we can conclude that the
original streaming problem was also
required large amounts of space because
if the streaming algorithm had been
super efficient in space then this
amount of communication would have
sufficed
for
the communication problem
so
so let me tell you what the index
function problem is and it turns out
that
uh
zohari at all use the index function
problem to show
this
lower bar okay and what's the index
function problem it's a very
natural problem alice has x belonging to
0 1 to the n
bob
or we can even change this let's say
alice has
and bob has an index i
in n
and alice sends one message
and bob needs to know
the
ith component
so
alice
has a long string
yeah you can think of it as an array of
length n each of which has t bits
and
bob has an index
and he needs to know this and alice
needs to send some information in the
end bob needs to know litty bits
but you can imagine that
if you want to accomplish this alice
essentially has to send
the entire input over
okay so
so
what is known is that
these are t bits
in order to solve this problem even
randomized
with some reasonable probability of
error uh you
alice has to send the entire input even
though bob is interested only in
one of them and alice bob right in the
beginning doesn't know which alice
doesn't know which one bob is interested
in okay so
i'm sure like
the point is that there is just too much
entropy and
you have to send
all of it here okay
this is called the index function
problem
the augmented index function problem
says
that in addition to
i
bob is also given
x 1 x 2
up till x i minus 1.
that is when bob
when we ask this when bob needs this he
already somehow knows
that is given to him so it's not
independently generated input alice's
input is generated uniformly let's say
and then a uniform i is chosen
and
bob is given everything
before that and he has to find out what
this is and alice needs to help help bob
in doing this
so
turns out that you still need
omega n times t
communication for this augmented index
problem
if you set this up with n and t both as
log n
then this number turns into log n square
and that is the source of this lower
ball okay
so they
managed to show that if you could solve
the streaming problem in less than log
squared gig communication then you could
have solved this augmented index
function problem with
words of length t
and
with ah sorry of log log n and
array of length log n
efficiently and but that requires log
squared and communication okay i don't
have time to
tell you more questions yeah just this
moment so this means that if x i minus 1
happens to be x i then alice now has a
very efficient way of just saying look
at my previous input basically yes
that sort of won't happen that will yeah
does not happen often i mean
h of x is h of x one plus h of x 2 given
x 1
h of x
3 given x 1 x 2
and so on yeah i don't want to insult
you more
so
if
the message is small
then
there will be lot of residual entropy
even after seeing the message about
something and this x
x 1 to x i minus 1 is essentially what
is being given here so what appears here
in our information theory formulas
is appearing here in the input and
that's how you analyze this problem so
you can just write down entropy and get
this done but i'm really out of time
question
thank you yeah thank you
thanks largely
so any more questions
concluding questions
meaning
a deterministic to deterministic
argument
so it's one of
those very pretty things you had a
deterministic problem you turned it into
a randomized problem and used the
randomized lower bound to conclude
something
yeah
it's one of the gems
so yeah so it's a randomized lower bound
for the kashmir victorian game but uh
yeah
amazing
okay great thanks a lot